what's up guys my name is Colin McNeill
for the score eSports you know there's
just something special about a grand
final on land there's energy in the air
the stakes are high
the crowd is loud it's the place where
csgo legends are born sometimes it's
also the place where rosters can
collapse where dynasties go to die where
hopes and dreams at glory can fade away
with that diverse criteria in mind here
is our list of the top 10 most impactful
and memorable csgo grand finals of all
time starting things off at number 10 on
our list is fanatics return to glory at
IEM katowice 2018 where they managed to
win their first premier championship in
two years it took seven hours five maps
149 rounds three overtimes and to ace
clutches from flush up to beat the
star-studded lineup of faze clan that
gives flush to the upper end as well
flash out he's faced off of it forced
off the angle at flush just got us going
the distance as he hits the shot we tie
things up in the end it was the Swedes
lifting the hardware remembering what it
felt like to win again
the first three time IEM champion and
Carrigan can't believe they've come up
shy and had another final Janet Anne on
this stage no one predicted this grand
final between underdogs gambit and the
second best csgo team from brazil
immortals this grand final was
incredible for so many reasons
zeus fulfilled a promise he made a year
prior to win a [ __ ] major dosha
gave us an unforgettable grenade Flay
and gambit made history as the first CIS
team to win a major
for the crime funnel
it was Dreamhack Montreal 2017 immortals
were forced to forfeit the first map of
their best of three Grand Final against
north after three of their players
showed up late to the match this is I
think over 50 events for me in the last
four years is the first that's pathetic
by immortals North won what would be the
first and only map of the finals in an
anticlimactic win that robbed viewers of
the clash of Counter Strike Titans they
had been promised and in one map they
win a best-of-three that's right because
the gifted the first one and they clean
up let that not be an asterisk beside
North's performance however they were
excellent throughout this whole event it
would have been a challenge for
immortals either way FNS would take to
Twitter and remark that the immortals
players were out late due to partying
too hard the night before now whether it
was purely in jest or not one immortals
player in particular did not take the
comment lightly in response to that was
the tweet that shocked the csgo
community and eventually broke up emails
faze clan entered the finals of IEM
Oakland 2017 as a heavy favorite ninjas
in pyjamas had taken the entire
tournament by surprise by making it to
the finals but nobody expected they'd
actually be able to beat phase well they
did with some crafty play and a lot of
aggression it was get right forest rez
exists and Drakon who defied the odds
and put on a grand final that reminded
us why n IP are legends in
counter-strike
[Applause]
at Dreamhack Leipzig in 2016
luminosity gaming showed that Brazilian
csgo should be taken seriously by
finishing in second place for the second
consecutive big event
invented in Austin it's sometimes so
odd game and well paid to them then at
MLG Columbus they solidified that fact
when they crushed Navi 16 - in the final
map of the tournament taking home their
first big title win Guardian versus taco
it may just be destined to fade and it's
throwing off the team winning their
first major championship
for a long time a stralla interred every
major tournament as one of the favorites
but could never quite get the job done
the first Elite major would break that
curse for astralis when they defeated
virtus Pro in spectacular comeback
fashion has to stop for more kills and
they will have made it at the full
distance nak silicon a comfortable
position he goes down with the max and
he can make it happen finally Pasha
coming in with the refract buddies down
the palm has been picked up by Dupree
they get the spray Neal takes one in
town today and as strong as they win the
first major championship 1614 against
furfrou unbelievable the champions
Estrada's
[Applause]
the grand final of ketamine say 2015 saw
two of the biggest juggernauts in
esports go toe-to-toe for a major
championship this series was well fought
and ninjas in pyjamas pushed it to a
third map for the second time product
with one Friday
[Applause]
continues 1513 but they just didn't have
what it took to defeat fanatic on
Inferno caminito champion top phonetic
our number three grand final harkens
back to the beginning of luminosities
legacy which actually started in
crushing defeat at Dreamhack open winter
2015
Connie smashed the dreams of luminosity
in goes the first set of Meister horse
called out of this position there's the
peak
the defeat at the hands of fnatic would
mark the beginning of the Swedish CS
juggernauts new run with Denis replacing
pronax there were just a cut above
everyone else in 2015 at ESL one cologne
fnatic put a stamp on one of the most
dominating runs in the history of csgo
the Swedes defeated envious in a
decisive two consecutive maps to win
their third major title then ladies and
gentlemen it's gonna require a miracle
and nothing less for happy to make it
out I don't think there's any chance
flusher looking to end with this win
that fnatic roster may have cemented
themselves as the best team in csgo
history it may have only ended less than
two months ago but this one was an
instant classic nowhere near the
favourites headed into the tournament
cloud nine were set to take on gu
powerhouse faze clan they came from
behind in the final map of the grand
finals on the back of incredible mental
resilience and veteran like play to push
the tournament favourite faze clan to
double OT and eventually make history
[Applause]
we'll be talking about this one for a
long time to come
as Kyle my steps to push up
[Applause]
come join
major champion
[Applause]
well guys that was our list but if you
think we missed a csgo grand finals that
should have been in this top ten I don't
know what to say go make your own list
or something thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button